or so people have asked me why I don't
like the Star Wars prequel snaggin go on
and on about it but instead of telling
you why I don't like those movies so
much I'd rather tell you what I like
about the original trilogy to give a
long remembered Star Wars a lot of
people call it Star Wars a new hope nope
I'm calling it what it was back in 1977
when it came out this is Star Wars the
other two movies in the trilogy they'll
get their own video all right so Star
Wars is an iconic classic and a sci-fi
genre and movies in general and I think
for good reason this movie is really
good yeah it's been overhauled a hundred
times over and I'll mainly talk about
the movie as it was released in 1977 you
know the real version that you can find
and like one DVD and that's it and I
will compare it to the special edition
just to talk about what I did and didn't
like this is a review after all in any
case Star Wars starts out on the planet
Tatooine it's kind of a shitty little
planet it's like a desert and no one
wants to live on Tatooine if you're on
Tatooine you were either born there or
you're an old hermit who lives in the
mountains those are the only two options
and Luke wants to fight in the rebellion
but he's trapped there cuz uncle Owens
like no you're not going to become you
know you're not gonna fight you're not
gonna do anything you're not going to
become you know like your father and you
don't really know what that means until
he runs across obi-wan Kenobi he used to
be a Jedi and he's like oh yeah your
father was a Jedi Knight just like me
and it was awesome and times were good
and Darth Vader killed him
all right Darth Vader is one of the most
menacing forces in the history of movies
you see this guy walk on screen for the
first time he comes through the fogger
like yep that's the most evil person in
the galaxy right there and yeah he is
best character in the movie they'll Han
Solo why cuz he's a smuggler for one
every guy likes a smuggler those are the
man's men of men han Solo is one of the
best characters ever made honestly this
dude takes no crap Princess Leia dishes
crap to him and he talks crap back I
find that absurdly entertaining and he's
a total mercenary he's in it for the
money he even says she's like I don't
care about your revolution I'm not in it
for you I'm in it for the money
han Solo will grow over time yeah and
that's what I like about this you can be
a douche bag as long as you grow over
time and you know you snap out of your
douchiness and this is where the special
edition really started to screw it up I
can roll with some changes but once they
get the moss eisely to get off of
Tatooine so they can you know do their
mission the regular edition shows moss
Eisley is this little thing he knows
like yeah it's it's I suppose
big spaceport intact oween but Tatooine
sucks a moss eisely is not going to be
that big and George Lucas had the Lucas
a fight it with a bunch of CGI crap he
just didn't need the worst change of all
the moment of silence here it is Han
Solo's Jabba the Hutt money he's a
smuggler he had to dump some spice now
he owes him cash RINO comes up he's like
a going somewhere solo sit down let's
talk green I was going to kill Han Solo
originally green I was like oh I've been
waiting for this a long time that's
pretty much a cue that I'm going to kill
you in Han Solo's like yes I'll bet you
have blows him away right under the
table now grito shoots first I don't get
that that is slapping the character and
the fans in the face
George Luke's his reasoning behind it
was like well I don't think you can
redeem someone who would shoot first not
counting the fact that one of the main
aspects of Star Wars is all about
Redemption yeah but you shoot a bounty
hunter from under the table you know
that's the line right there darkside
nothing that is it didn't make any sense
and I hated it and another thing that he
added in was actually a scene that was
going to be in the movie that he didn't
originally have in the movie he filmed
it though was when Han Solo talks to
Jabba the Hutt this scene I prefer to be
out of it why because for two movies you
hear about this Jabba the Hutt who's
pursuing han Solo and you never see them
during Majan ation starts running you're
like what is this job of the Hutt who is
he he must be horrible if you see him in
the original Star Wars it's like oh yeah
I know what Jabba the Hutt is ok it's no
big surprise when you see him in Return
of the Jedi so that's better left out so
after they get off of Tatooine they try
to go to Alderaan Alderaan yeah it's
it's gone why because the Death Star can
blow up planets you think the Senate
approved that you think the Emperor was
like ok we're gonna build something
called the Death Star and is that like
Ronald Reagan Star Wars project or
something no no we're in Star Wars but
this is going to be the Death Star in
Star Wars trust me it's gonna be awesome
in any case they built this thing called
the Death Star which is funny because
everyone gives Vader credit for that
everyone's like oh yeah when Vader blew
up Alderaan it wasn't actually Vader no
one gives credit to Grand Moff Tarkin
this dude is not only bad but he is
someone who Vader takes orders from you
know invaders choking that one dude he
was like I find your lack of faith
disturbing
Tarkin was like Vader release him
Vader's like ok Darth Vader's kind of
like the Jew hunter and inglorious
basterds he's probably the worst case
scenario that you're going to run across
and he is absurdly bad but there are
people who outrank him that being said
I'd probably rather deal
with those people invader Vader can
choke you with his mind that's not good
so while in the Death Star they saved
the princess that is a plot point that
every NES game for the next five years
after the system's release is going to
follow they get the princess and obi-wan
Kenobi squaring off with Vader now this
is awesome this is monumental this is
awesome for a couple of reasons at this
point all you know is that Darth Vader
used to be a pupil of obi-wan Kenobi he
even says when I left you I was but the
learner now I am the master he never had
an apprentice I don't care what those
stupid cartoon say and so they square
off into this day I don't know who could
have stomped - I feel like obi-wan
Kenobi could have beaten him but Obi one
knows it's not about him and he looks
over to Luke and he just gives it up and
Vader just slashes him down right there
Vader's a dick obi-wan is awesome I just
like old dudes that are all wise like
that like not I'm smarter than this this
is the best case scenario slice me down
props to obi-wan and Han for shooting
first because he does so after that you
have the climax of the movie there on
Yavin they find out what the Death Star
plans are like if you shoot a little
rocket down the porthole that thing will
just entirely explode yeah I know it
doesn't make much sense but it is what
it is and it makes for a simple and
entertaining end fight to this movie
because if you look at Phantom Menace
there were like four things going on
that's way too much man you don't need
that just give me a straight-up fight
the rebels were assaulting the Death
Star they needed to take it out and so
here we go so Han Solo takes off before
they even do the battle yeah you know
what I gotta pay off some debts
you haven't seen Jabba the Hutt because
he wasn't actually in this movie and
that's how it should be but I've seen
him and I gotta go pay him off good luck
in your fight and among all this Darth
Vader's like yep okay I'm gonna go out
there I'm gonna take care of some
business - Darth Vader does that's
reason 151 he's not as high up on the
Empire as you think he should be because
he actually did stuff we all know how
corporate types are they don't do
anything getting their TIE fighters and
fight off the rebels they sipped their
tea and you're like wall could you check
it out already I have to cut payroll and
fire people and at the end of aiders
trying to lock on to Luke and Luke's
evading like this and videos like hernán
the force is strong with this when we've
taken out all the fat pilots and the
pilots with the porn-star moustaches but
this guy he's got the Force Robin he
locks on you see the TIE fighter next
one just exploded you don't know why it
just happens han Solo comes back to save
the day
this is why Han Solo's a badass he's
like yeah I'm all about the money and I
care but I won't let you know I care
besides I got a really cool medal at the
end but Chewie doesn't because that's
just the way the world were
in the end the reason Star Wars works is
because it's all about the characters
and it doesn't shove Darth Vader down
your throat you know a little bit about
Vader you know he used to be Obi Wan's
apprentice but he's not like he's like
you know Christ gone bad who should have
brought balance to the force or some
weird they're all part of a bigger
story in the end you know I'm gonna give
Star Wars awesome tacular so I'm just
saying Star Wars is awesome tacular Star
Wars establishes the characters
perfectly for a trilogy it sets it all
up the next movie straight-up takes it
to a whole hazard level that's another
video for another time I'm saying this
right now I'm talking about the 1977
original version George Lucas has
improved the video and audio quality of
Star Wars in the special edition so I
can give him that but he made too many
other alterations I can't roll with so
if you watch the original trilogy or
sacrificing video quality for quality of
content I will take quality of content
any day of the week I actually give
George Lucas credit for creating Star
Wars I mean it was hard to do there 151
problems but it added to the quality of
it you can tell he was like no I put
love into this this was actually back
when George Lucas says something like
special effects or means to tell the
story but it's not the story special
effect without a story is a pretty
boring thing he said something like that
that's real the dude actually believed
that at one point now everything just
sucks he's like uh if I could CGI
something I'll do it which is reason 151
I believe a t-1000 came back through
time terminated him has been
impersonating him ever since if he would
released the original Star Wars trilogy
on blu-ray unaltered but really good
quality dude that'd be perfect merry
Christmas to the world so your favorite
Star Wars movie what is it comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you